Traductor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Desde que existe el lenguaje,
hay quienes han tratado de controlarlo.
Y algunas de las metas más frecuentes
de esta regulación de la comunicación,
son los “mm”, “eh”, “como”,
que sazonan nuestras conversaciones.
Textos en latín y griego antiguo
advertían de hablar con vacilación,
las escuelas modernas han intentado
prohibir los términos ofensivos
y el famoso lingüista Noam Chomsky
descarta estas expresiones
como “errores” irrelevantes del lenguaje.
Históricamente, estos componentes
del habla se han agrupado
en una lista más amplia de “disfluencias”,
rellenos lingüísticos
que distraen del habla útil.
Sin embargo, nada de
esta controversia ha hecho
a estas disfluencias menos comunes.
Siguen ocurriendo casi cada 2 a 3
veces por minuto en el habla natural.
Y distintas versiones de ellas
se encuentran en todos los idiomas,
incluso en el lenguaje de señas.
Entonces, ¿los mmhs y ehs son
un hábito que no podemos romper?
¿O significan algo más de lo que oímos?
Para responder, sirve comparar
estos componentes del habla
con otras palabras que usamos a diario.
Mientras que la palabra escrita
puede tener múltiples definiciones,
en general se puede determinar
la intención del significado
por el contexto.
Sin embargo, en el habla,
una palabra puede tomar
niveles adicionales de significado.
El tono de voz,
la relación entre los interlocutores
y las expectativas de la ruta
que una conversación tomará,
pueden infundir incluso palabras
que parecerían rellenos
con información vital.
Aquí es cuando los “mm”
y “ah” entran.
O “eh”, “ejem”, “esto”, “este”,
Los lingüistas les llaman
pausas sonoras,
que son un tipo de fenómeno de vacilación.
Y estas en apariencia
interrupciones insignificantes
son de hecho muy significativas
en la comunicación hablada.
Por ejemplo, mientras que una pausa
de silencio se podría interpretar
como una señal
para que otros empiecen a hablar,
un pausa sonora puede indicar
que no has terminado.
Los fenómenos de vacilación dan tiempo
para ordenar las ideas al hablar
o de encontrar la palabra correcta
para una situación.
Y no solo sirven al que habla,
una pausa sonora permite
que los oyentes sepan
que viene una palabra importante.
Los lingüistas incluso han descubierto
que la gente tiene más probabilidad
de recordar una palabra
si surge de una vacilación.
Los fenómenos de vacilación
no son la única parte del habla
que toma un nuevo significado
en un diálogo.
Palabras y frases como
“bueno”, “como”, “ya sabes”
sirven como marcadores del discurso,
que ignoran su significado
literal para transmitir
algo acerca de la oración
en la que aparecen.
Los marcadores del discurso
dirigen el flujo de la conversación
y algunos estudios sugieren
que los hablantes conscientes
hacen más uso de estas frases
para asegurarse
que todos son escuchados
y comprendidos.
Por ejemplo, empezar
una oración con “Mira...”
puede indicar tu actitud y ayudarte a
tantear el consentimiento del oyente.
“Quiero decir” puede indicar
que estás por elaborar algo,
Y el odiado “como”
puede tener varias funciones,
como establecer una conexión
suelta entre pensamientos,
o introducir palabras
o acciones de alguien más.
Estos marcadores le dan a la gente
una visión en tiempo real
de su proceso de pensamiento
y sirve para que los oyentes
sigan, interpreten
y predigan lo que intentas decir.
Los marcadores y
los fenómenos de vacilación
no solo son útiles
para comprender el lenguaje,
también sirven para que lo aprendamos.
En 2011, un estudio mostró objetos
comunes y raros a infantes
junto con una grabación
que se refería a uno de estos objetos.
Cuando una grabación
posterior les preguntaba
que identificaran los objetos raros,
los infantes lo hacían mejor
si la instrucción tenía una pausa sonora.
Esto pudiera indicar
que las pausas sonoras
dan pista a los infantes
de esperar palabras nuevas
y les sirve para conectar palabras
nuevas con objetos nuevos.
Para adolescentes y adultos
que aprenden un segundo idioma,
las pausas sonoras suavizan
conversaciones de inicio incómodas.
Una vez que tienen más confianza,
el aprendiz del segundo idioma puede
mostrar su nueva fluidez encontrada
usando el apropiado
fenómeno de vacilación.
Porque, contrario a la creencia popular,
el uso de pausas sonoras no reducen
el dominio de un idioma.
El hecho de que los fenómenos de
vacilación y los marcadores del discurso
sean una parte natural
de la comunicación,
no implica que siempre sean apropiados.
Fuera del diálogo escrito, no tienen
un propósito útil en la escritura formal.
Y en algunos contextos, el estigma
que estos apuntes sociales conllevan,
pueden funcionar
en contra del hablante.
Pero en la mayoría
de las conversaciones,
estos sonidos en apariencia sin sentido
pueden transmitir
un mundo de significados.